Traduttore: Marta Cerutti
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Vi devo confessare che
nel settembre del 2014
ho completamente perso la testa.
È successo a Londra,
nell'aeroporto di Heathrow.
Ed è successo per colpa di un trolley.
Io sono stato per molto tempo quello che
viene definito un frequent flyer.
Ho passato una gran parte
della mia vita sugli aerei;
non li ho contati tutti,
ma credo di aver salito quella scaletta
almeno un migliaio, 1.200 volte
nella mia vita.
Ed ogni volta che viaggiavo,
con me c'era il mio trolley.
Perché il trolley per un frequent flyer,
per un viaggiatore assiduo,
non è un oggetto qualsiasi:
è un vero e proprio compagno di viaggio.
Ci sviluppi un rapporto di amicizia,
fa parte della tua vita.
E cambiare un trolley
non è una scelta facile,
perché il trolley ha una sua vita
anche quando non viaggia.
Perché quando resta a casa
custodisce oggetti come il tuo passaporto,
il secondo mazzo di chiavi della macchina,
il caricatore del telefono,
il caricatore dell'iPad,
la camicia sottovuoto che avevi
portato via e pensavi di utilizzare
e invece non hai utilizzato,
il beauty,
che contiene tutti
quegli oggetti miniaturizzati,
perché tutto deve essere miniaturizzato,
per cui lo spazzolino da denti,
quello telescopico,
la schiuma da barba, quella piccolina...
Sostanzialmente la tua vita
si miniaturizza
e va un pochino sottovuoto,
perché quel trolley deve essere pronto
poi in pochissimo tempo,
a riempirlo e svuotarlo
per il prossimo viaggio.
Io non so quale sia stato il motivo
per il quale quella mattina,
quando sono partito da Milano,
ho deciso di cambiare trolley
ed utilizzarne uno nuovo.
Perché come dicevo,
cambiare trolley è una scelta importante:
intanto perché lo devi svuotare;
secondo perché,
per chi come me
è anche un po' scaramantico,
lasciare un trolley con cui hai fatto
centinaia e centinaia di voli
e ti è sempre andata bene,
non è proprio una cosa
che fai volentieri.
Però quella mattina ho deciso
di utilizzare un trolley nuovo
che avevo comprato qualche settimana prima
insieme a un mio amico.
Parto per Londra,
ho due giorni di meeting.
Parto dall'aeroporto di Linate,
tutto funziona benissimo,
arrivo il venerdì alle 5 di sera a Londra,
devo rientrare a Milano,
faccio una di quelle cose
che ho fatto normalmente,
in una giornata come tutte le altre.
E per quelli di voi che
sono stati a Heathrow,
probabilmente ricorderete che prima
di entrare al gate della sicurezza
c'è un box di metallo
all'interno del quale
tu devi posizionare il tuo trolley,
perché questo verifica che le dimensioni
del tuo trolley siano compatibili
per portarlo in cabina,
per portarlo a bordo.
Io arrivo sereno,
spedito come sempre,
cerco di incastrare il mio trolley,
e per qualche centimetro
- tre, quattro centimetri -
il trolley non entra nel box.
Allora l'addetto alla sicurezza mi guarda,
con gentilezza, con fare British, mi dice:
"Guardi, per favore, si sposti dalla fila,
vada al check-in
e imbarchi il suo bagaglio".
E io ho detto:
"Non se ne parla neanche
che imbarchi il bagaglio!
Allora, mi faccia provare di nuovo".
Provo di nuovo, provo a spingere
tra il manico, insomma,
non c'è possibilità,
il trolley non entra.
Allora questo addetto mi guarda,
questa volta un pochino più severo,
mi dice: "Guardi, sta procurando
un certo disagio agli altri passeggeri.
Si faccia da parte,
Vada al check in,
imbarchi il suo bagaglio",
e io lì, non so per quale motivo,
perdo completamente la testa:
inizio a gridare come un pazzo,
a inveire,
un po' in italiano, un po' in inglese
a un certo punto,
e credo che non sono finito nei guai
per le parole in italiano
che lui non ha compreso.
(Risate)
Tutti quelli che mi vedevano da fuori
hanno visto una scena improbabile,
finché questo signore,
con un certo piglio,
mi dice: "Guardi, se non la smette
sono obbligato a portarla
nell'ufficio di Polizia dell'aeroporto,
per cui, per favore, si faccia da parte
e faccia passare gli altri passeggeri".
Io me ne vado, trafelato, sudato,
rosso, paonazzo,
con probabilmente 200 su 140 di pressione,
e decido però che non gliela darò vinta.
Per cui mi sposto di qualche metro,
strappo fisicamente, con le mani,
le rotelle dalla base di questo trolley,
che era un trolley in nylon
con la base di cartone,
strappo le rotelle, mi spacco un'unghia,
mi sanguinano le mani,
le butto nel cestino e come un pazzo
mi dirigo verso di lui
guardandolo come in una sfida
da film western,
(Risate)
piazzo il mio trolley dentro,
funziona, entra;
lui mi guarda e mi fa passare.
(Risate)
E io arrivo finalmente al gate,
uno straccio praticamente,
perché un uomo che ha passato
una gran parte della sua vita
ad essere sempre molto sotto controllo,
francamente, a un certo punto,
non ho compreso cosa mi fosse successo.
E mentre ero al gate, aspettando l'aereo,
rifletto su questa situazione
- è stata davvero
una situazione particolare -
ho provato a guardarmi da fuori
e, ho cominciato a farmi qualche domanda.
E mi sono domandato:
"Ma, per quale motivo,
sono arrivato in questa situazione
di totale disequilibrio,
da avere una reazione di questo tipo?".
La risposta che mi sono dato
è stata: tempo.
Perché non volevo imbarcare
il mio bagaglio?
Perché volevo guadagnare
20 minuti di tempo all'arrivo a Linate,
perché di questo stiamo parlando
quando imbarchi un bagaglio.
E la domanda, quindi è stata:
ma se il tempo è una di quelle parole
che continuo a ripetermi in continuazione:
"Vengo quando avrò tempo",
"Ho bisogno di avere un po' di tempo",
"Ci sarò con un pochino più di tempo"...
"Tempo" era una parola ricorrente,
che era così importante
da farmi perdere la testa;
e allora che importanza stavo dando io,
nella mia vita, al tempo?
E ho pensato, quindi, che "tempo"
era una parola importante,
le parole sono importanti,
perché le parole,
se le usiamo correttamente,
possono avere un potere straordinario.
Così ho deciso, e ho riflettuto sul fatto
che in fondo, io, persona
istintiva ed emotiva,
ho sempre avuto le parole
come uno strumento razionale,
un contraltare alle mie decisioni
nella mia vita di business.
E avevo 4 parole chiave, un acronimo:
CCTY
Questo era un sistema di decision making,
io lo usavo per prendere decisioni.
Significava, ogni cosa che fai,
nel business, devi essere sicuro di farla,
prima di tutto, nell'interesse
dell'azienda, Company;
Secondo nell'interesse dei clienti,
Customer;
then, dopo, nell'interesse del Team,
della tua squadra;
e, infine, nel tuo personale interesse.
E se questo può essere uno strumento
che nel business
può essere valido per sempre,
perché, può piacere o meno,
si può condividere o meno,
ma è una struttura che ti permette
di prendere decisioni
secondo un senso logico,
ho detto, allora perché
non fare la stessa cosa
e applicarla alla mia vita privata?
Io non avevo un acronimo
per la mia vita privata.
E così ho detto, allora, andiamo a vedere
quali sono le parole che mi guidano oggi,
che mi hanno portato
in questo tipo di vita,
e mi hanno portato
a questo tipo di reazione.
E ho fatto un esercizio semplicissimo:
ho preso un foglio di carta,
e ho cominciato a scriverle.
Denaro,
Stabilità,
Status,
Ego.
Erano parole importanti per me:
il denaro era importante,
lo status era importante,
l'ego era importante,
e la stabilità anche,
non volevo una situazione con dei rischi.
E poi le ho cerchiate per dimensioni,
cercando di capire quale di loro
fosse la più importante,
per costruire quello che era
il mio inconsapevole acronimo
che guidava le mie scelte di vita.
E non a caso ho scoperto che era MESS,
era un casino!
(Risate)
E allora ho detto,
proviamo adesso a scrivere
quelle che invece sono le parole
che vorrei inserire nella mia vita,
quelle per cui vorrei prendere
le decisioni da oggi.
E le parole sono state:
Tempo,
il tempo è importante.
Perché il tempo è importante?
Perché volevo più tempo?
Perché volevo tornare a casa,
perché volevo tempo da spendere
per le mie cose
e con i miei affetti.
Io non credo a tutti quelli che dicono
che l'importanza del tempo
non è la quantità, ma la qualità.
Questo per me è stato un alibi
per tutta la vita,
perché la quantità, negli affetti,
aumenta la qualità.
Che era lo scopo!
(Applausi)
Volevo avere uno Scopo,
volevo Multidisciplinarità;
avevo passato 25 anni della mia vita
sempre nello stesso settore,
nell'information technology.
E poi volevo Persone,
le persone erano importanti,
volevo scegliere le persone
con cui lavorare.
Poi volevo avere Divertimento,
perché il lavoro può essere divertimento.
Quando per la prima volta
ho cambiato lavoro nella mia vita
e ho detto a mio papà:
"Papà, cambio lavoro
perché non mi diverto",
lui mi ha detto: "Ma tu sei pazzo!
Se vuoi divertirti vai allo stadio!".
Il lavoro è fatica,
perché nella nostra concezione
il lavoro era fatica.
E poi volevo avere un Impatto.
Così, ho ricostruito la mia mappa,
cerchiando le parole
in funzione dell'importanza
che dovessero avere,
e ho costruito il mio nuovo acronimo:
TIPP,
che curiosamente, in inglese, al gerundio,
diventa "tipping point", punto di svolta.
E poi li ho messi a confronto:
ho messo quali erano le parole
che mi guidavano
e quelle che avrei voluto
che diventassero le parole
con cui fare le prossime scelte di vita.
E così ho fatto una cosa che,
fino a qualche settimana prima,
non avrei mai pensato di fare:
ho dato le dimissioni.
Ho lasciato dopo 20 anni,
all'apice della mia carriera,
l'azienda per la quale avevo lavorato,
e ho lasciato, soprattutto,
tutte quelle cose
che l'azienda mi aveva dato:
status, bigliettino da visita...
Il mio cognome è tornato
ad essere il MIO cognome.
Io non ero più Bevilacqua di,
ma sono tornato ad essere
David Bevilacqua, quando
mi presentavo con le altre persone.
E ho cercato di riempire la mia vita,
per rispondere a queste parole.
E come avete sentito,
ho co-fondato un'azienda
grazie a un brillantissimo ragazzo
cesenate, che è qua in sala,
Marco Ramilli, di cybersecurity,
svolgo attività di advisor
per diverse aziende,
e svolgo attività in
alcune aziende no-profit.
Avrei potuto evitare che
ci fosse stato quel momento tilt
all'aeroporto di Heathrow,
ma non l'ho fatto,
perché ho sottovalutato i segnali
che avevo ricevuto.
Il nostro corpo è il primo
a darci dei segnali.
Io, negli ultimi due anni,
avevo avuto molti più guai di salute
di quelli che avevo avuto
nei precedenti 49 anni della mia vita;
niente di grave, grazie a Dio,
ma tutta una serie di problemi
che non ho saputo leggere
con la giusta attenzione.
Per cui, il messaggio che vorrei darvi è:
ascoltate i vostri segnali,
perché il nostro corpo ci dà dei segnali.
E poi fate manutenzione delle parole;
Noi spesso utilizziamo le parole
senza sapere che senso e che forza
possano avere.
Mi è venuto in mente un libro
che avevo letto di Gianrico Carofiglio:
"Le parole servono a comunicare
e raccontare storie.
Ma anche a produrre trasformazioni
e cambiare la realtà.
Quando se ne fa un uso sciatto
e inconsapevole e se ne manipolano
deliberatamente i significati, l'effetto
è il logoramento e la perdita di senso
bisogna sottoporre le parole
a una manutenzione attenta,
ripristinare la loro forza originaria,
renderle di nuovo aderenti alle cose".
Io ho sempre avuto bisogno
delle parole nel business
per dare un contraltare razionale
alle mie possibili decisioni emozionali,
e per questo per me funziona,
perché non credo che la risposta
sia sempre: mollo tutto
e vado a vivere in Sud America.
Ognuno deve fare i conti
con le proprie parole;
non ci sono parole fisse,
le parole sono dinamiche
e cambiano in funzione dell'età,
delle circostanze, dei sentimenti
e di quello che viviamo.
E quindi, io, adesso, guardando avanti,
ho aggiunto una nuova parola.
L'ho scritta sul mio libro,
come suggerisco a voi
di prendere il vostro foglio
e scrivere le vostre parole.
E la parola che ho scelto è: Scelta.
La scelta di poter continuare
a fare solo le cose che amo
e con le persone che stimo.
E questo spero che sia una parola
che troverete nel vostro blocco
che io spero inizierete
a scrivere stasera.
Grazie.
(Applausi)